Have you ever felt like your faith is threatened when you walk into a science
classroom? Maybe you've felt like science and faith are at odds.
Or maybe you've even heard the narrative that science and faith are at war.
Should we feel like our religious beliefs are threatened when we walk into a science
classroom? Well, it's easy to think that we ought to check our religious beliefs at
the door when we come into the arena of science.
But as tempting as this may be, this is not an option for a thoughtful Christian.
You might be pleasantly surprised to discover that it's actually the Christian
worldview that is largely responsible for the birth of science.
You see, there are certain ideas within the Judeo-Christian tradition that gave both
the motivation and the intellectual backing for the birth of modern science.
Many scientific pioneers, if not most scientific pioneers,
were motivated to do science because of their theistic and in particular Christian
belief system. Scientific pioneers like Copernicus, Boyle, Galileo,
Kepler, Newton, and many more did science because of their Christian
worldview.
Francis Bacon believed God meant for us to explore the many mysteries that filled
the natural world. Kepler wrote, the chief aim of all investigations of the
external world should be to discover the rational order which has been imposed on it
by God in which he revealed to us in the language of mathematics.
Newton believed his scientific discoveries offered convincing evidence for the
existence and creativity of God.
This most beautiful system of sun, planets, and comets could only proceed from the
counsel and dominion of an intelligent and powerful being.
There are three main reasons why the scientific revolution took place in a culture
shaped by a theistic worldview. The first reason is that Christianity in particular
teaches that God is orderly, he's rational in his very being, and the universe is
orderly. And since we're made in God's image we are capable of understanding the
world in which we live. The world is not chaotic, it's orderly.
Second, Christianity sanctioned science.
In other words, science was done to care for and alleviate the suffering of human
beings and to protect and care for creation.
And third, Christianity gave the motivation is that science was to be done to bring
glory to God.
Despite the common narrative that we hear that science is at odds with faith.
It's actually the Christian worldview that contributed enormously to the rise of
science.
Naturalism actually undermines science.
Charles Darwin once said, but then with me the horrid doubt always arises whether
the conviction of man's mind, which has been developed from the mind of lower
animals, are of any value or at all trustworthy.
Would anyone trust in the convictions of a monkey's mind if there are any
convictions in such a mind?
In other words, what Darwin is saying is that his very naturalistic evolutionary
theory undermines any basis we have for concluding that evolution is true.
Now here's why. According to this naturalistic theory, the brain is the result of
this blind purposeless material process.
It's a large accident. So this raises a troubling question.
How do you know we can trust anything that the brain tells us is true?
Now, this isn't a problem for the Christian worldview because God is reasonable, the
world is orderly, and we've been made in God's image to understand the world in
which we're placed. You see, naturalists can do science, but they have to borrow
from the Judeo-Christian worldview to do so. Science and faith are not
at odds. Now there certainly are distinct scientific and distinct theological
questions. For example, in science, the question of how many oxygen atoms are in a
water molecule, or in theology, what is the nature of an angel? Those are distinct
questions that belong in their own discipline, but there are times when science
and theology overlap. Questions such as the origin of the universe, the origin
of mankind, and the historical resurrection.
Sometimes science and faith intersect.
The idea that Christianity is at war with science is mistaken.
It's a misreading of the historical, scientific, theological, and philosophical
evidence. You see, Christians have always taught that God speaks through two books,
the book of nature and the book of scripture.
The book of nature means that God has made himself known in creation.
Creation speaks truths about the creator but God also has made himself known through
the scriptures. God's word reveals truth about his character and also his design for
mankind. Now we can certainly misinterpret the scriptures and we can misunderstand
the scientific evidence. But when done accurately, both books reveal truths
about the Creator.